well I think we need to talk about the
dog in the room at this point yes Bubba
Murphy is here because Murphy wants to
meet Bob us so where's Bob I just ran
away seconds that is too much cuteness
he's 16 weeks so he's a baby that's
incredible now Kirsten I know that you
you've met Bob and you have two pups so
Mitch are you getting puppy I am dying
for a puppy I'm about to move houses so
I have to kind of reconsider everything
but I have three puppies
well three dogs one puppy we I have
thrown live oh my gosh I love it but how
wonderful it is to have these animals
right now during this time right so good
oh it's so nice you know we've been
touring for nine years and I've always
wanted a dog a dog guy for sure but I
just like I've never felt personally
like I could like raise a dog Christie's
a superhero that you can raise three
levels but I could and so this
quarantine time has been an excuse to
like Oh finally I can get a dog and
raise it without having to worry about
traveling there you go that's amazing
well let's talk a little bit about music
with everything going on in the world
right now why was it so important for
you guys to turn to your music you know
we're living in a really tough scary
time in the world and music has always
been an escape for all of us and we were
just getting really restless and we
wanted to put some joy out in the world
put some art out in the world and it
gave us an excuse to do something to
work on something to spend our time
creating art and I mean those covers are
so seamless and they're really
mind-blowing how long is the process of
getting them together it doesn't take
too long I think once we pick out the
songs and really set our mind to it the
arrangement process can be
anywhere from a few hours to a day and
then we all record separately now which
is really cool we all have our own
setups at home so it's pretty quick
really
yeah we have it down to a science now
because we just arranged hundreds of
songs and so we have like a system but
like our quarantine system has been a
little different cause to do it all over
the arranging and then we record on our
own so it does take a lot longer than
normal it's still like the same process
a little bit you've covered some of the
biggest names of music on this EP from
the weekend Billy I wish to do Lipa have
you had any reactions from them so far a
lot of times in the past we've gotten
reactions but I think that ups oh no we
haven't we ever had any reactions yet
but hopefully they see it I mean I the
Billy Billy Eilish is incredible they're
all so incredible I don't know how you
guys do it but it's so incredibly
beautiful um it's also been really
incredible seeing you guys shoot from
home Kevin you were even showing off
your Grammy um where are you guys
keeping your Grammys or anything
anything back there that I can see let
me show you a house tour you got we got
we got the Grammys right there the
YouTube 10 million subscriber thing
billboard number one that like puts it
right at the front I'm like oh oh my
goodness and love it and are you taking
us on a tour
crushed my little baby I'm so sad here
mine in my little studio room it's nice
your studio room can I see this is like
a host to her yeah so like Scott was
saying we're doing everything at home
this is where my computer will go the
microphone this is kind of like the
little corner where I've been setting up
doing like auditions or our own videos
it took a little white space and this is
my bookshelf and then there's my little
like art corner let me see I'm like
watching the floor now I don't have one
of my dogs
but yeah I just have like a little
corner little space
one of my nuggets is in the room as well
um but yeah it's nice to kind of create
your own little space and it is
definitely hard to do everything at home
with zoom but yeah it's been great I'm
really enjoying this house tour this is
Meghan oh this just a bunch of little
surprises now Mitch yeah where's all
your things show me around where am I
gonna see in your house what sure what
do you bet have you got for me okay is
that the best part about my house is
that there's nothing in it it's
completely I packed everything away this
is just like my big open living room
area I wish I keep in my house this
clean all the time it's really nice so I
can sing into my living room give me
some that was beautiful that was
beautiful talk a little bit about you
know speaking of being in your home's
all the tech I mean we don't have to
become our own tech people lately are
you finding that difficult or are you
embracing all of this
well we film our own videos that's been
such a challenge to learn how to record
ourselves there's pros and cons like
it's it's super difficult because you're
like setting up the mic and work
learning how to use Pro Tools which I
did not know how to use it all trying to
stop lighting no shadows like there's
like all these things you have to figure
out but the good side of it is I feel
way more self-sufficient than I've ever
been in my entire life and I it was
tedious to learn but I was forced to
learn it and so now I have those skills
for life which is like actually really
valuable so I'm glad that was a thing
but there was some frustrated I have to
take a 15 minute break moments setting
up the videos is always so hard for me
cuz you're trying to set up the lights
properly but yeah off the shadow and
you're
hot whole thing my hair is always like
doing all sorts of things in the video
but yeah I feel like it's really cool
we've always worked as a vocal producer
as well and so it's been really awesome
to monitor ourselves and listen back and
it's it's establishing a really good
work ethic and a really good like basis
of what you want to sound like because
there's no one there telling you how to
do it or to do it again you just have to
listen and make sure that's good enough
to send off and like good enough and
you're doing a good enough job doing it
yeah it sounds incredible I know you
guys are supposed to be going on a we're
supposed to going on a world tour this
summer
is it still mind blowing that you know
people are loving and consuming your
music the way that they are yeah it's
been nine years and it's been you always
I feel like we've always wondered like
when is this gonna fade out or like this
is all just like a dream come true
that's gonna go away and so when we like
sell all these tickets in Vienna Austria
and stuff we're like oh people are still
into it people still love the music we
make which is such a relief because we
love making the music we make and yeah
it's a dream come true what about for
your name Kirsten it's ten years almost
ten almost it's crazy
um yeah I mean it's amazing I feel like
we're so happy with the responses on the
EP you never know with everything going
on in the world right now but I feel
like getting so many wonderful responses
and hearing people say thank you so much
than you do this is just always so
rewarding so wonderful and especially
now and so we're so happy that everyone
loves it and is happy and we're happy to
continue to be working from our homes
and at least be creating and putting
something out so it's awesome and we've
always had a really wonderful super
loyal fan base so right and what about
for you Mitch yeah I mean I would I
would say the same thing Scott said it
earlier I know how important music music
is as an escape for us when we're all
going through a really tough time and
now the world is all going through it
together so it's nice to have something
that kind of you can rely on and relax
to but it also really unifies us which i
think is the which thing is the best
part yeah and I think the videos that
you guys
shooting from home definitely do that
because it feels very personal when
watching it and I think right now people
are hungry for things that are personal
so I think it's just really beautiful
what you're doing thank you so beautiful
you guys do great Christmas albums so
I'm just saying will there be another
one coming because I'm a little bit
obsessed with the holidays we are too
obviously but like you know we haven't
officially decided to do a new Christmas
song this year but it is we're talking
about it but this is not an announcement
away for Christmas so we're so bored in
our homes that I mean amazing is there
anybody that you that you want to cover
that you haven't done yet talking to
someone about this I've always wanted to
do the song hide and seek by Imogen Heap
do you know that song it's like it's
like that's like all these crazy
harmonies and I just feel like we would
we would kill it it's just such a like a
an acapella group type song but it's all
scary to cover so we've always liked and
like putting it off and for anybody else
mm-hmm I feel like well cover slash
collab I feel like it'd be really cool
to do a Celine Dion song left
collaboration with her because she yeah
the ultimate Queen I think time after
time by Cyndi Lauper oh wow that would
be good that just came that just came to
me right now
I love the Layton strike I see there's
going to be a Cyndi Lauper Thanksgiving
album maybe a Christmas I feel like
we've accomplished a lot here in Mitch's
getting it off so there's stuff to do I
will have a real puppy party
see that's amazing but thank you so much
you guys for your time be well and be
safe thank you